un semblant de calme a repris le dessus
ici à kiev vous l'avais dit il ya une
nouvelle explosion dans le centre ville
sans doute effectivement dû c'est en
tout cas la version officielle aux
ukrainiennes sortent du des débris de
missiles qui ont été touchés par le
système de défense anti-aérien ukrainien
mais en tout cas ici ici dans le centre
ville de la capitale pour l'instant le
salk le calme est revenu vous pouvez
voir sur notre derrière moi des voitures
circuler sur le sur la route et et
dépassant donc donc pour l'instant pour
l'instant donc centre-ville tout et tout
est plutôt au calme et stable et vous
revenez je crois un john d'une mission
dans le nord-est de kiev quelle est la
situation là-bas
alors c'était une journée très
instructive auprès d'eux pour près d'une
d'une brigade de l'armée ukrainienne la
soixante douzième brigade motorisée nous
étions à côté de grands varient sur le
front nord est autour de autour de kiev
près de kiev est là bas on a pu observer
que très clairement les forces armées
ukrainiennes était en train de renforcer
leurs positions et de stabiliser leurs
positions en périphérie de la capitale
ce qui n'était pas le cas il ya encore
quelques jours et puis nous avons pu
voir et filmé des missiles anti-char sur
ces sur ses positions et c'est ce sont
ces missiles qui servent à tirer sur les
colonnes de chars russes qui pousse qui
poussent vers kiev on a pu voir des
images de ces tirs de missiles sur sur
les chars russes qui ont été filmés
notamment par les drones de l'armée
ukrainienne on a pu voir ces images ces
derniers jours et nous nous avons vu de
nombreuses boîtes vides des missiles
encore inutilisés et des bunkers où ces
armes étaient entreposés donc clairement
ce qu'on a pu voir aujourd'hui on près
de 7 de cette brigade de l'armée
ukrainienne c'est que voilà encore une
fois ces positions sont en train de se
stabiliser et les ukrainiens sont bien
décidés à les tenir et empêcher les les
colonnes de chars de pousser plus avant
vers la capitale ukrainienne